você ia martin mas não já se acham que
chamamos de joãozinho
é isso ai de nós e aí galera que eu
chamei o canal tudo com vocês
olha só estamos aqui para mais um vez
neste canal que é sucesso em todo o
brasil que as pessoas me param na rua
para dizer você mesmo né ele mesmo
meu filho é seu fã and son eu diria meu
fã na coisa boa a de vitória da
conquista feira de santana camaçari este
final de semana de vocês em tela de
uberlândia este mês também deixou pra
vocês em uberlândia contra o ingresso
vai ser na arena sabiazinho
com isso nosso voto br eu viajo muito o
brasil inteiro porque eu faço shows
nessa é muito bom e eu fico muito hotel
é assim eu não gosto de assistir
televisão mas quando resolveu assistir
televisão sempre nos hotéis só pega pra
mim tu 23 canal que é vencer na polishop
aquele discovery channel que eu adoro
assistir porque eu adoro a natureza
adoro veículo do mundo só tem as coisas
não entendo quando consegui entender
assim o dia que eu liguei assegurada
passei penha estava tentando falar
aquela voz
o beija-flor bate suas asas mais de 80
vezes por segundo
a mostra já foi camelô lenta que a
pessoa sabe que foi a pergunta da
que contou eu pensando na falta do que
fazer uma pessoa que conta os batimentos
das asas de um beija flor porque imagina
o diálogo de duas pessoas famintas a
beija-flor bater asas mais de 80
veículos e um é essa no todo que fala em
2000 para bater as asas 80 evento
segundo maluco segunda 12 o segundo já
começam não tem como não meu amigo eu tô
falando é com estudado o rapaz foi
embora com o trabalho de câmera é a bota
bagutta greve como elevar a r 12 ou
beija-flor conecta das plantas e leva
tem os seus filiados ea câmera já tá lá
no ninho dentro de mim eu fico pensando
como o diabo esse cara com essa câmera
de turim
do beija-flor é que ele sabe que nem ele
não tem como o cara fala olha que ele
beija flor a par de boyle o filho faz a
cara do pai ou um jeitinho sobrancelha é
uma coisa e os caras lá 88 89
não consigo entender não quero assistir
assim na minha cabeça fica pensando um
bilhão de coisa é aquele cara que fica
aí tentando sobreviver na selva aquela
eu tenho ódio aquele cara tem é ótimo
programa começa amanhã helicóptero é
cara tá pra entrar nessa ilha
eu não tenho como pousar então eu vou
ter que pular nesse rio cheio de
crocodilos que não comem há uma semana
tomara que eu tenha sorte a ele pulou no
rio e pula cai lá com jacaré mesmo fosse
comigo para falar só é só tem como
entrar nessa ele pulando essa água é a
saga sem dormir jacaré eu ia voltar para
lá venha falar o reparo porque não deu
nem para gravar
chegando lá o cara disse que tinha 15
mil jacaré na água eu achei impertinente
não é da minha parte o popular dessa
água ele fica perdida ele
estou perdido tudo está perdido o cara
foi lá e deixou está muito bem você tá
se quiser embora só se levantaram assim
eu vou morrer ela vai pegar você faz
tudo perdido
estou com medo eu estou me desgastando o
que é isso
essa arrancada faz a maior seca do mundo
a pegar uma rã e essa hum o seu sangue
com 50% de água que pode me dar todo 29
minutos ele rasga ram no mês ela assim é
só um pingo ó hidratou hidratado ainda
dono depois e agora temos que atravessar
essa cachoeira tudo é que não bebeu água
da cachoeira então rasgou a ram no meio
carro assim o coxa matou a rã bicho tem
a cachoeira e eu tenho que me segurar
bem pois eu posso cair dentro dessas
áreas perigosas que tem sete tipos de
sanguessuga diferente ou de dez pessoas
que entram 14 morrem incluindo idosos e
crianças se os caras lá e 9 muito rápido
rafaela através de redes a agora estou
cancelando não tenho roupas para bonecas
é melhor eu me apressar pois se o sol
entrar eu posso morrer congelado que
mesmo o meu deus um camelo a cara mata o
cabelo
[Música]
agora sim dentro desse cabelo eu posso
passar a noite e me aquecer bean é mais
pessoal agora dorme dentro da barriga do
camelo também tinha nada a ver com isso
camilo e os caras lá 43 do que fala num
amigo já amanheceu e agora começa a
ficar muito quente o deserto mais
perigoso do mundo e não tenho mais o que
beber pode até morrer desgasta desta na
cachoeira bebeu run já entrou de camelô
a nota 10 é mais quente do mundo que não
têm água porque não chegou a pé da
cachoeira pertinho por ficar aberto é só
fica fora se em caixinha espera nada de
aula de bh embora a mata que mesmo
entendendo o cabelo aí não tem uma rampa
bebê e beberrão engraçada apple 2 milhão
a favor 9 horas em hams só dose de razão
pra mim hoje eu quero beber muito melhor
dose de cururu eu estou no deserto a
imagem vai se distanciando assim vai
mostrando que está no deserto
helicóptero filmando o deserto mais
perigoso do mundo
não pega o helicóptero embora o
helicóptero está com fome de gols e ir
embora ou se buscará que está filmando
ficar assim a morrer mesmo falar do
dundo tarde tranquila por dedé ser muito
bem trabalhado bem está tudo ficava lá
não muito corressem metro e fica dando
dicas de saúde pois o primeiro planeta
eu acho que vou ter que voltar para as
águas e tem o jacaré vão ser as únicas a
razão de possuir webber morte na zaga do
jacaré o jacaré bem pertinho ele perde
já tá eu não posso beber muito dessa
água pois é ela pode causar mal é uma
água muito pesada ao ver seu bebê tenha
diarréia orbitará quando o jacaré vem
aqui e joga bocha de levar a vitória
régia essa vitória régia esta planta é
uma boa fonte de água e na vitória régia
em 1 hora na água quando bebe a água que
a vitória está bem só vai ganhar com a
vitória já estava bem a vitória não deu
pra galera vitória régia a coisa que eu
mais tenho o rabo esse programa é
colocar isso aqui a gente agora está
essa borboleta a esse mosquito é um
alarme tão grata pela coin e os caras lá
né centrei aí tanto meu amigo de 64 a
segunda porto canal é animal planet o
filhote de cervo corre grande perigo
o leão se aproximar
pensei meu deus por que o câmbio não
ajuda o filhote de cervo é um ataca
comercial na sua expedição
meu deus tem o programa que aquele
encantador de cães então quer dizer que
o seu gato gente atacou é o meu gato
quebrou a minha mão ontem à noite é eu
acho que ele tenha personalidade forte
personalidade forte esse gato é o
demônio mas se chama encantador de cana
chama um padre um pastor e oscar al
assad deve treinar e aí merda pedir a
conta pode comer de novo vídeo então é
isso aí você tiver gostado deste vídeo
aquela que você comece aqui embaixo é
que acha mais estranhos programa de tv
clique em gostei aqui no youtube e se
você está assistindo youtube clique
gostei não esquece tá tá no twitter fora
bateu recorde de r t no twitter 5 mil r
3 na postagem do vídeo o vídeo novo
discórdia no facebook tem que curtir
galera se você veio pelo facebook você
foi notificado pelo facebook aquela
curtida tamo junto é nóis nas redes
sociais são essas aqui você pode seguir
no instagram no twitter e facebook para
sempre enquanto tiver um vídeo novo você
sabe né vai que o turno se anuncia
tamo junto é nóis egan